or the Sufi path is is described as
being based on that emotion as a
starting point and then the path is this
path of returning of returning to your
beloved and uniting with them again so
the utmost again the the
at least somewhat the the final stages
of that path is to unite with God which
has certain sometimes erotic and even
sexual themes you know of uniting with
with the Beloved
um but it's all metaphorical of course
um I did a video about Arabia and some
of that um love poetry and many people
were upset the Muslims would be upset
and like how could she say this this is
heretical to talk about God as your
husband and having sex with God but of
course it's all metaphorical it's just a
way of expressing that kind of ineffable
experience of of love and longing